c'est à ligueil en terre tourangelle
kahn a trouvé le sol et le climat idéal
pour faire pousser des légumes japonais
elle pensait s'installer plus au sud
mais le jardin de la france l'a séduite
c'est chaque oeil les aubergines dos
alors ça certaines mises au nassau en
japonais et ce sont les aubergines
d'origine de osaka on en mange beaucoup
à kloto aussi et ce sont les aubergines
qui se mange cru à ce fonds à la main et
puis on les mange entièrement fraîche
comme ça avec la peau qui est tout
tendre ça c'est des haricots km ce sont
des variétés qu'on d'okinawa dans le sud
du japon
donc c'est le japon c'est un long pays
donc au nord c'est pas presque la russie
mais il fait très froid il ya trois
mètres de neige et au sud il ya des îles
presque tropicale et c'est étonnamment
j'arrive à voir les haricots km
d'okinawa ici à ligueil 69 m2 chaude
soja avant de lancer son exploitation
maraîchère anna d'abord testé durant six
mois la culture de ces légumes et dammam
et fèves de soja apprécié l'apéritif ou
concombre amer un classique de la
cuisine familiale des légumes de saison
sans pesticides
j'en ai une dizaine par saison donc sa
saison printemps été et automne hiver
donc une vingtaine en tout et encore
j'ai essayé de diminuer parce qu'au
début je voulais faire ça ça fait après
c'était trop de travail
et puis les pour les restaurants ça les
intéresse pas d'avoir 2 3 et pinard un
jour et rien après donc c'est vrai que
j'essaye de m'adapter à la demande donc
j'essaye de peut faire mais as bien un
un livre aujourd'hui une dizaine de
restaurants à paris des étoiles et des
restaurants japonais ou de cuisine
française avec des chefs japonais
friands de ces légumes
ce sont tous des grands chefs qui ont
des restaurants de petite taille mais un
gastronomique
de haute qualité qui travaillent des
légumes de saison selon l'arrivage dons
qu'ils ouvrent mon carton il arrive à en
faire des choses incroyables
aujourd'hui ça va l'ambassade du japon à
paris l'ambassadeur du japon un client
fidèle ces cuisiniers viennent
régulièrement voir le travail d'analysé
y ana authentique ambassadrice des
légumes japonais en touraine